for this quiz I want you to experience
the web without images install links in
chrome box you can find some links in
the instructor notes once you do visit
an image heavy web site ask yourself
what is it like experiencing the web
without images and try listening to a
site with chrome Vox if all you had was
chrome Vox could you figure out what the
images were trying to tell you making
your website accessible to everybody is
incredibly important because not only
does it make you a good person it means
that more people can experience your
website so when you check this checkbox
down here it means that you are
promising to use alt attributes
responsibly